[Music]
hello
and welcome to playstation grenade it's
time once again to look over all the
secrets and
map changes in the world of fortnite
battle royale
we've been doing this for three years
now so i reckon you know the premise
so slap code adam arrow in the store to
keep this series going
and let's break down chapter 2 season 3
week
8.
it finally happened eight weeks after we
saw the teaser video
drivable cars and trucks are here in
fortnite
the map feels full once again let's be
honest what was the first thing you did
when you jumped in a car
i crashed i flipped mine completely i'm
a dreadful driver
by the way i'm in need of vehicle myths
for the next myth chaser video and
ideas for a vehicle themed meetup with
you guys too so i'll be stalking in the
comments for inspiration
but right now i traveled across the
stream to visit somewhere
close to our hearts hud watch baby
our little baby boy is now growing into
something awe-inspiring
the second layer looks to be complete
with a roof and a fancy fence there too
but this is not the end of this erection
wood pallets as drone
everywhere and the chairs aren't in
position yet
with only around three or four weeks of
the season left yeah i
i know it's going to be extended but
judging by that time scale
this isn't going to be finished in time
so it appears that hut watch will
continue into season four
any guesses on what this could be i have
a feeling that this will be some sort of
homage to
chapter one kinda like camp cod but with
totally irrelevant items
like the chairs that were found in
westworld and maybe
a stone man to remember the brilliance
of the stone family storyline
remember those days good times bro above
the hut watch build the truck has now
returned and the final cleanup is on
this street will likely be completely
clear next update
but that pallet truck and that chair
truck will never be forgotten for the
gift
they gave us man i'm gonna cry can i get
a hashtag pop watch for life in the
comments please
thank you kindly
[Music]
so i got to thinking and remembered that
truckasaurus
had no head last week he crawled onto
the shore above the docks
but his head didn't appear and i said
this
but here's a cool thing to note this
confirms truckasaurus's head
will be a drivable vehicle in fortnite
well check this out right now i was
right optimus does have a head again
and yes it is a rideable vehicle by the
way were you expecting raps to work on
cars
i was so i'm keeping an eye on the store
for a red and blue optimus prime style
so i can cosplay in
game i know what you're thinking right
now adam you're a loser
yes you're right oh wait if truckasaurus
head is now a vehicle
then we can take him to meet his
arch-nemesis
the splashback spartan it's a long
journey
but i think we can do this autobots roll
[Music]
out
[Music]
three hours later this is it
truckasaurus do your thing boom
take that spartan my allegiance is with
truckasaurus
now go be free my pretty your work here
is done
just as a note that joke took far longer
than i expected
to make it's almost impossible to get
trichosaurus's head
all the way across the map on your own
totally worth it though
[Music]
suddenly i got a mysterious message from
arch over in my discord he told me to go
to unit 4 at the nuclear plant
i obeyed this call and went to steamy
stacks
there i heard a strange sound and by
breaking the floor
we can find a secret underground
facility here
and there is more by breaking another
wall things get
mighty interesting
first the music changes to tell us this
is important
but what the heck is this thing i have
no idea
it could be an intergalactic key maybe
is this what will create the new season
of content
it's time to delve down into the law
here my friends hit me with your story
theories please
in the meantime i'm just gonna listen to
this music again it's epic
whilst traveling back through atlantis i
once again try to understand what the
heck these fish bowls are
and notice there are shells to toot on
here and one thing which confuses me
are these things in the ground plugs are
they called plugs in different countries
if it's not called a plug i apologize
the thing which stops the water going
out of the water basin
anyway anyway the reason i bring this up
is it just a cool design
oh will this let atlantis vanish back
next season
i'm not sure but they do look impressive
okay let's check out our minion friends
it's been time since we visited and holy
heck balls batman
they have evolved once again look at
this mini city
the detail is great the castle area
remains
yeldi english style but surrounding this
the buildings are ultra modern
there are even billboards on the roofs i
wonder if these are clues
let's look closer it's not easy to see
but one of the signs is advertising a
pizza restaurant
maybe to signal the food fight returning
another is telling us about a rocket
launch
we'll come back to that in a second and
the third one
here what could this be telling us i'd
love to know your thoughts
this place has gone through so many
changes from the og settlers
to the evolved encampment all the way to
this great structure now
it's impressive but i'll always remember
this place for the viking with the axe
what a guy this is not the end of the
update though there are two secret
missions to uncover this week
just by the egyptian temple is a rocket
testing facility
with minions waiting for something by
grabbing 100
metal we can take part in a space
program
more advanced than that one in my own
country we're gonna launch a rocket
check this
i'm starting to love these micro events
did you hear the voices too
well it's too cute well there's more do
you remember those pirates that joined
the settlers after the piranha island
was eradicated
well there is still one remaining he's
hiding away just by this rock but keep
an ear out for the ticking that can be
heard
get close enough and you'll find one
pirate protecting a nuclear
container be sure to relieve him of this
nastiness and take that item to the
testing area close by
you'll know where it is because this guy
is waiting for you
we can now i can't believe i'm going to
say this
we can now perform an atomic test
this is all kind of messed up complete
with mushroom cloud
i no longer trust these crustaceans
these guys have become far too advanced
they're like jelly bean axolotls waiting
to take over the island
they must be stopped keep an eye on them
please in last week's update i showed
you a funky basketball court and
challenged you to make a trick shot or
two well here's a few from the first day
impressive stuff but i think we can go
bigger and
better i want to see mind-blowing
three-pointers please
my twitter dms are open i'm adam grenade
over there
let's see some more quality basketball
shots and finally the spaceship we
epically launched last week
didn't go very far we found it again it
turns out
he didn't make it anywhere at all the
intergalactic travel didn't go according
to plan
and now the vessel is here here's the
thing to note
the door is open the astronaut has moved
on
i've tried to find him but to no avail
so please do your best to keep an eye
out for the male astronaut
i'm pretty sure he's the link to the new
season with all the space vibes going on
everywhere right now
will we find him and trigger the next
event
by the way we found a way to get him
outside of the ship last week
and we tried to launch a shark into
space too i'll uh
link you the video if you're interested
in myth chasing shenanigans
so there we have it week eight of season
three how did i do
and what did i miss the biggest update
is those vehicles and i need ideas and
suggestions for myth chaser myths and
meetup ideas too please
on screen now are the next bunch of code
adamaru legends who have used my code to
buy something in the store this week
thank you very much much appreciated if
you want to join the legends roll call
i'll put the info in the description
below i'm adam from playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you